what's up what's up man are you a Muslim
I'm becoming one you're becoming a
Muslim yeah um I I was an atheist and
then I read some some some Islamic the
Quran firstly is what first converted me
and and I just had a about about
Christianity wait what's convincing you
that Islam is true the the line
connecting the Quran to the to the Quran
reviewed by Muhammad first the the line
what line yeah there's proof that the
Quran that we have today is connected to
the Quran that that that was revealed to
to Prophet Muhammad like what what do
they give you what what what lies did
they give you I want to know lies no not
lies there's the Quran that's that's my
friend memorized and that I read is is
directly connected to the Quran that was
revealed by Muhammad and what about what
about my friends that memorize the Quran
in Morocco who recite it differently
than your friend does it it it's not the
Bible it doesn't have that many
translations it has it I I understand
we're not talking about translations I'm
talking about Arabic the same Arabic is
different in different depending on
which Quran you read yeah of course it's
the language so there shouldn't be any
differences if it's all one language
right there's different types of of
Arabic doesn't prove your point there's
different types of Arabic yeah of course
how many how many types of Arabic are
there search it search it good googly
moogly they already got to him Christ is
is begotten and the begotten word it's
it's never mentioned in the Bible that
that's that he's Eternal hello chat no I
yes but uh if you go to John to
Colossians 15 it says that that he was
begotten and if you search up begotten
in the dictionary it says to be put
forth how how can some be be put forth
if if if something is is is eternal
nothing can be put forth if if it was
eternally existed because Eternal
Eternal means that it was always present
and for the people that are saying that
they searching Google and I I I don't
know much about Islam but I I I had
questions concerning how how can
something be be put forth to earth like
it says in the Bible if it's Eternal I'm
I'm I'm talking to you the the guy left
he pause the video the Creator will be
back soon yeah the was begotten yes
begotten if you search up in in Oxford
dictionary if if if it's Eternal all
right sorry my phone it's okay it's okay
it's it's okay no I just no I I was just
trying to ask the definition of of
begotten means to be put forth how can
something what dude why are you going
away from the subject that we're talking
about what were we talking about how you
believed in Islam because the Quran goes
back to Muhammad okay cuz I got kind of
C no uh I I I I was an atheist I looked
at Christianity and then I looked at
Islam and then I I read you said that
you said that yeah then I read I asked
you why you you being convinced that
Islam is true you said because there's
proof that the Quran we have today
traces back to Muhammad yeah remember
there's no yeah yes okay I remember so
my question is this let's say I give you
that how does that make the Quran true
just because it traces back to Muhammad
it just means that it's well it's well
preserved and God and God's language
God's
Revelations yeah the Quran was written
in in Arabic you know God's language is
Arabic no it's it's like the the gospels
which were written in in Greek and and
yeah and it's supposed to be translated
all right so how does how does the Quran
being well preserved make it true it
could be well preserved and be false
doesn't make it true it just makes the
others seem less likely because you
don't know what's really true like you
don't know that the current Bible that
we have today is is the is the gospels
released by the church fathers early on
in in Christianity the Quran says that
the gospel released today is the same as
that that they had in Muhammad's time no
the Quran says that that it it has been
corrupted where in uh someone said Islam
is real Islamic brainwashing is real
I'll tell you that that's the only real
thing about it they be immediately
making these guys Bots someone named
Friend of the Devil said this host is
exhausting get off the bed got logic if
if how can you prove that the Bible has
not been translated and and and changed
by King James or early on in the in the
BR in the Dark Ages when the church when
the church
accepted because the Quran says so yeah
and and and even after the
Quran yeah after the Quran I'm talking
the 1500s when King James Bible was the
Torah in the
was the Torah and the gospel Allah's
words before yes it it was a revelation
good chapter 18 verse 27 of the Quran
says no one can change Allah's words so
your Quran says that no one can change
the Torah and the gospel they're Allah's
words yeah but it's not literally the
the word of of Allah like the Quran
is it's Revelations wait where do your
where do your say that the Quran admits
to be to be the the re the actual word
of God it says that we sent down to them
we sent down the Torah and the gospel
talking about Allah it says about the
Psalms it says we wrote in the Psalms
for David So Allah says he's the one who
wrote the Psalms he's the one who wrote
the Torah he's the one who spoke the
gospel and gave it to Jesus so these are
the words of Allah what are you talking
about yes I know I didn't re rebuke this
no I I just said that like how can you
say that even after the the Quran proved
that I'm going to go with you and see
that it proved that the gospel the Jew
and and the Torah were were correct
because Muhammad believed that they were
were proven I'm not going to argue
against that because I know it's true
how how can you say that even after the
Quran like in 1500s in the Dark Ages the
church I'll tell you this if the if if
the go if in the
1500s the Torah and the gospel got
changed and corrupted then your Quran is
false since it says no one can change
any of Allah's words so that will prove
the Quran wrong okay make sense yes yes
yes makes sense as a Muslim you have to
believe that the Torah and the gospel
has been preserved or else you'll be
going against the Quran
okay okay and but how does that prove
Christianity it just just kind of
disproves the the the beliefs that some
um that some Muslims have that that the
gospel has been changed well it so
number one your your religion is telling
you that Christianity is true because it
says that our book is true and
unchangeable and if our book is true and
unchangeable then that would mean that
the Quran is false because the Quran
contradicts our book that it says is
true it says Jesus died by crucifixion
rose again on the third day Jesus is the
son of God who came into the world that
he the father and the Holy Spirit share
the same Divine Essence as the Triune
God the gospel says all of these things
and the previous prophets say these
things so okay so so if the gospel is is
correct then the Quran is wrong the
Bible is true then yes okay so and
because the Bible is true the Quran is
false
the words okay and if the Bible is false
then the Quran is still false because it
says it's true okay but that still
doesn't answer like theology questions
and and concerns that's were developed
in in in in the schisms in the in the
heresies that's formed after the Quran
was was published like it does it
answers what what what's denomination
are you of I'm an I'm an original Quran
only Christian Quran only original Quran
only Christian so that's cath Catholic
Orthodox I believe in the original Quran
that affirms the catechism and affirms
Orthodoxy it affirms prism
protestantism the essentials the core
doctrines that affirms them okay so so
you believe Christianity based on the
Quran no I believe in Christianity and
in my Christianity I also believe in the
original Quran that existed that agreed
with Christianity before it got
corrupted so the Quran got corrupted the
original Quran used to agree with
Christianity but your Quran doesn't
today it got corrupted my Quran our
Quran got corrupted and in what grounds
do you see that what grounds do I say
that well there's Hadith that talk about
Usman the third Calif who while he was
compiling the qurans it says that they
used to disagree on their on on the
Quran how it was recited and stuff like
that and it says Usman please save our
people before they defer on the Quran
just like the Jews and the Christians
defer on their book so uan had Zade
babit hasham and a few others compile
the Quran together collect people's
Quran they made one perfect copy in
usman's eyes perfect copy that he saw
fit and then had the other qurans burned
have you ever heard this before no
really oh hold on I can't just I gotta
show you this I can't just tell you this
I gotta show you let me let me show you
bro it's sah bukari are you do you know
what the you know about the Hadith yet
yes of course all right good good good
so this is inside bukari all right let
me I'm G turn my screen around so that
you can see you can see this this is
something that I can't just tell you I I
need you to see it yourself give one
second is is just scrolling always takes
a little second for me to get it I never
save this one for some reason stupid of
me I need to save it yeah understand
wait so God La so you believe that the
protestantism protis that the
Protestants are are correct Protestants
are true Christians are true are true
Christians and how do you explain the
the church history before and and
everything that's went against
protestantism I don't think that
everything goes against Protestant
Protestants and there are Protestants
that hold to early church tradition so I
would say the Protestants that reject
the Protestants that reject Church
tradition will have a hard time
answering your question but yeah but
like like theot toos is the main the
main component that butter sense
disagree with and it's been proven
throughout all of the church history so
well whoever who well that that doesn't
take you out of Christendom you can have
disagreements that doesn't take you out
of Christianity yeah
why why did Jesus like not FOC
yeah sorry all right so this is the
Hadith let me zoom in all right so it
says narrated anas bin Malik this is
sahkari
4987 okay all right Huda bin Al Yaman
came toan at the time when the people of
sham and the people of Iraq were Waging
War to conquer Armenia and okay at
harban Huda was afraid of their
differences in recite in the recitation
of the Quran yeah of course if everybody
memorized it the same way and had one
Quran why are there differences because
like like the church happened things
aren't specifically made clear you you
can't say this this is this isn't about
theology this isn't schisms these are
Quran readings they're reciting the
Quran and they are they have different
recitations of the Quran different
translations no it's not translations
all of these people speak Arabic these
aren't translations but every Quran has
the same sunna TOA there's no it do
change in that no it doesn't no it
doesn't so why so why are they why are
there differences in recitation of the
Quran and notice if it's just little
simple stuff why is hudaa afraid about
it why is he scared about these
differences
because it it can lead people to to not
to false to falsehood and how will they
know what is false and what isn't how
they know what's what's the prophets
originally said how do they know because
they're all saying that they got it from
the prophet they're all saying they got
it they memorized it from Muhammad where
do it say that dude all of these people
these people from armania Huda was
afraid of the people of sham and Iraq
their differences in the recitation of
the Quran okay okay but like um okay
this you don't have to say anything it
gets worse so he said to umman oh chief
of the Believers save this nation before
they defer about the book The Quran as
the Jews and Christians did before now
this is even getting worse about
theology about all kinds of stuff the
differences are so big that it can split
the religion I thought onean what Sur is
that just oh but you want the theith
yeah yeah theth
4987 okay thank you thank you and yeah
but this this also doesn't prove
Christianity like it can also said
didn't say I know I know I know sorry
sorry but this can also be this point
can also be raised to Christianity no it
can't because when we have textural
variance no one is afraid of our textual
variance splitting Christendom no one
there's no fear among the early church
about the textual variance that existed
and arises matter of fact they give
commentary on it they invite them they
show oh you know this manuscript says
this and we do it's there's no hiding it
there's no none of that there's no and
and watch what happens you're going to
see the difference between how you guys
handled the variants and the differences
so bad that they will split your
religion I'll show you what you know
what what Islam did as opposed to what
Christians did had the counil had the
council sothman sent a message to haa
saying send us the manuscripts of the
Quran so that we may compile the quranic
materials in perfect copies and return
the manuscripts to you H sent it to
utman now there's other Hadith talking
about how haa refused she she was
apprehensive at first I forgot how they
got it but they ended up getting it but
she refused at first I can show you that
laterman then ordered Zade bin Tabit
Abdullah Bin zubir s Alas and hasham
hasham to rewrite the manuscripts in
perfect copies if there's already one
Quran and one perfect copy why do they
need to rewrite it yeah I guess it was
splits I don't know man said to the
three Ki men now watch so they have the
copy
and they're rewriting it in perfect
copies right now watch in case you
disagree with Zade bin Tabit on any
point in the Quran then write it in the
dialect of qu the Quran was revealed in
their tongue hold on a second why in the
world if they're already they're writing
perfect copies why in the world would
there be any disagreement on any point
if they're writing one perfect copy of
the Quran well it's it's human nature
people tend to disagree got it human
nature cool no worries it's human nature
to disagree on the Quran which are even
which shows that this idea of perfect
preservation has a little crink in it
because this is human preservation okay
let's keep going and let's see whatman
did all right so they did so they did as
he as as he told them when they had
written many copies umman returned the
original manuscripts to haa which we do
not have no evidence of utman sent to
every Muslim profin one copy of what
they had copied which we have no
evidence of and watch what he did and he
ordered that all other konic material
whether written in fragmentor
manuscripts or whole copies be burned
why did Usman have all the other
evidence all the other chonic material
other than the one that he saw fit why
did he have the rest burned to to to
keep people from to keep people to to
the truth to keep people to the truth
now this is interesting because you
brought up the councils in Christianity
when when they had their disagreements
or disputes about let's say the cannon
for example or what supposed to go be
part of the connect the Canon what was
inspired what wasn't this where you get
Apocrypha books and you know extra
biblical books y y did did the Bishops
and the church fathers did they have
these other writings burned no they had
them disproven burned ah very good so
they were able to disprove these other
writings they were able to refute them
show how they were Fabrications and not
correct while without having to burn
them without having to be afraid of
people going after these books because
they refuted them however utman had to
have the copies burned to keep people in
line you don't find that interesting
yeah yeah I do but it's like the like
the the Muslims at the time didn't have
the the resources to come up with a
council you the doctrine what are you
talking about they got it right here
they have a whole meaning they have a
whole little team you have Usman the
caleff who has people that he trusts you
have Companions of Muhammad you still
have IB mud who's out there you still
got uh Umar IB kab who's out there you
still got the companions of Muhammad who
are still alive just like Usman is who
who recited the Quran who knew the Quran
by heart people who Muhammad pointed to
and said if you want to learn the Quran
from learn it from these people none of
these people are mentioned here IB mud
is not mentioned here UB KB is not
mentioned here these people are still
alive though so they have the re the the
resources to come together and say hey
guys let's figure this out but no
instead uthman handpicks four people who
are related to him by the way little
nephews and sons-in-laws and whatnot
people that you know he has influence
over and has them rewrite the copy of
HSA in what he sees as a perfect copy
and then burns the rest burns the other
konic material whether fragmentor and
whole corons were burned bro whole
qurans which contain false Doctrine or
no how do you know that because I I
don't know exactly you know yeah this
this this is the I'm sorry Raphael this
is the point you don't know if these
whole copies actually contain the truth
or not and that it's uthman's copy that
has the corruption and has the false
Doctrine this is why I am an original
Quran only Christian because the or I'm
saying the original Quran was tempered
with here this is where it happened but
do you believe that's like when when the
church chose the gospels and chose what
would be put in the New Testament do you
believe that it was God inspired like
the Holy Spirit was that inspired them
to choose the the the gospels because
the be said I believe that're we're okay
we we have we have the idea the concept
that the Holy Spirit Led and guided the
church through all these years so for
you you don't have that does did did
Allah Inspire or tell utman to collect
the Quan and do what he did maybe no no
no he didn't this is Allman's doing on
his own accord so you don't have the
same beliefs that we do you don't have
the same situation yeah but we don't
know that like in the Council of niia
where where the gospel was where where
the New Testament was chosen that it was
it was
Thea Rafael that didn't happen at the
Council of NAA Council of NAIA had
nothing to do with the cannon the
Council of yeah the Council of NAA was
about the deity of Christ the Bishops
the fathers were refuting Aras a heretic
the Aryan right yeah aryanism yeah yeah
okay so when the gospels when the New
Testament was chosen you believe that it
was the impacted by the holy spirit
because the same thing that you said to
I believe that the Holy Spirit I believe
that the Holy Spirit continued to guide
the church fathers and the Bishops in
refuting Heretics in calling out
falsehoods with these Gnostic fabricated
writings absolutely God has protected
and preserved his church yes okay is
there something that proves that or or
do you just believe well I mean we we
have the history of the church that says
so we have uh Jesus who says that he's
going to build his church on Peter and
that it will never fail the Gates of
Heaven will not Prevail against it
that's number one number two you have
Jesus saying that heaven and earth will
pass away but his words will by no means
pass away so Jesus says this happen
right Jesus says he'll protect his words
and protect his church it says that the
Holy Spirit guides and appoints people
in the church and protects them what
church the Orthodox Catholic Protestant
Church of Christ the body of Christ bro
that's what it is so the church a phys
although although you know it's not it's
not physical it's the body of Christ
it's the body of Believers that's what
the church is so even even though
Catholics and Protestants or Orthodox
have dis agreements they're still part
of the same body of Christ you know so
you might have some Fanatics that you
know talk fear each other but they're
wrong to do so but anyway but here we
got bro this is this is the history of
the Quran and you're saying that it all
traces back to Muhammad but this is not
what Muhammad did or ordered this is
Allman well it might be Muhammad there's
nothing Muhammad's nowhere in this yeah
but the the Quran came from from The
Inspirations of Muhammad no the Quran
that that you have is most likely came
from The Inspirations ofma the third
kaith yeah sure um no I mean like it can
and it canot be it's like I maybe you
know so so I I I just I want you to man
The the same courtesy and generosity
that you're giving to this situation I
want you to have the same attitude
towards the New Testament and towards
church history cuz we don't have nothing
as close to Messy as this but yet you're
still you know giving excuses for this
imagine Raphael if Paul or araneus or
somebody had the scriptures burned went
against some of the other Apostles
against their wishes and had some new
testament manuscripts burned yeah imag
people would say that that it was the
Holy Experience holy spirit's inspiring
no do it would be it will be a mess it
be a mess and you as a Muslim you would
be like see see logic look Paul burned
the Scriptures it shows the corruption
right here and I wouldn't have a defense
against that no okay but so you gota you
got to look into this bro matter of fact
follow me I'm on YouTube as well there's
a guy has a YouTube channel his name is
GI and DLC I'm GNA put it in the in the
chat so you can see how it's spelled GI
and DLC he he speaks Arabic and
everything and he and DLC DLC stands for
daughter of Christ both of them speak
Arabic fluently and when I tell you that
they are awesome at this topic bro I
mean they know all the type of sources
they know they know it all man and they
they will break this down to you I have
them on my channel we're going to be
doing this topic again coming up pretty
soon so you got to you got to look into
this bro these these GI and DLC my
brother ji he can he can he's the one
who taught me this stuff yeah okay okay
but like I I I agree with you with that
but like the I see some videos that's
like some Muslims hold some truths about
their doctrines that's like seem truth
you know it seems like the real truth
and and when you try to look up about it
it is a real truth like there's some
truth in the religion also like what
give me give me an example like okay
like uh wait what the some truth about
about Islam yeah what what's a what's a
truth about Islam that you have been
able to confirm is the actual truth well
the the the Allah like one Gods I guess
one God yeah one Gods that's okay so
there are there are other religions that
believe in one God so how does that
prove Islam true Christianity believes
in one God yeah but I mean I guess the
the scientific miracles of the Quran
maybe that can be another points okay
let's go with that the scientifical the
scientific miracles of the Quran so if
the Quran let's just grant that it that
it had some scientific knowledge that it
got right let's let's grant that if it
got any scientific claims wrong would
that make it a false book sure I guess
okay I like that you're consistent if
scientific Miracles scientific knowledge
is good enough to prove the Quran then
scientific
inaccuracies are good enough to disprove
the Quran if we're being consistent yes
all right so I'll ask you this what was
created first the heavens or the Earth
the six Heavens were created all right
beautiful right in the universe right
the six Heavens which would be like you
know the universe space galaxies and
even other Realms right the other
Multiverse I guess so the universe was
created before the Earth that's what we
know scientifically and that's what you
would say as of right now right all
right do you have a computer on you or
like a Quran I do perfect go to chapter
2 verse 29 two wait wait a minute and
logic would you believe that there are
also um like scientific contradictions
in the Bible as well no I don't but I
also don't believe that the Bible is a
scientific book like I wouldn't I
wouldn't use scientific I guess claims
to say see this is the word of God I
don't I don't think that that proves or
disproves a book to be from God yeah but
if if like a scientific proof like was
was was done by this like if if the
Bible was proved to be to have to hold a
scientific like false like something
false about about science would that's
like change your opinion about the Bible
no again no because my opinion isn't
based off of science I don't believe
that the book is a the Bible is a
scientific book it doesn't yeah it's not
a scientific book so no but if it's it
contains false information about it
would you still hold it accountable I
don't know why you keep pressing this my
my Bible's not I don't I don't believe
that there's any scientific falsehoods
and if there were I wouldn't change my
opinion on what the Bible says on its
theology because it's not a scientific
book okay okay then uh then show me the
the CR I I
am okay no I'm not pressing you just
just I I I I got my my with me chapter 2
verse
29 chapter 2 verse 29 okay so go ahead
and read it out for me he's the one who
created everything in the Earth for you
then he turned towards the heaven for me
into seven heavens and he was perfect
knowledge of all things so you see how
it says the seven Heavens were created
after the Earth who created everything
in the earth then yes that is scientific
impossibility but but you think it
should be taken literal like that's cuz
like uh it says that the day that the in
the Bible Genesis says that that the
Earth and Heaven was
created the Bible doesn't help you bro
you can't go to the Bible make an excuse
for the Quran remember my book I'm not
making the claim that scientific
Miracles prove the Bible true you said
this you said that this points to the
Quran being true and from God while I
said okay so we both agreed that okay so
then the then the reverse is true then
that scientific inaccuracies would prove
the Quran false you said yes I don't
hold the same view the Bible the Bible
doesn't help you okay so how how does
this this prove the Quran it says that
the Earth was created before the heavens
when we know scientifically it's not
true why is it not true how does the
Earth being created before the heavens
make before the heavens because the
heavens is the universe bro it's the
that's the universe that's space that's
the galaxies that's all the Realms and
stuff it's I'm not sure it says like
that you know like very literal though
like I mean like doesn't this might not
be the the interpretation that that you
read it's
from it's just it's just what it plainly
says it literally says it is he who
created everything for you on the Earth
right so the Earth is done and finished
then then he rose up towards the heaven
and made it seven Heavens okay so the
seven Heavens came after the Earth the
universe came after the Earth according
to this verse okay and and how do you
like this proed the scientific Miracles
that are mentioned like I I agree that
this seems kind of false but but how
does like the other Miracles that that
aren't possible to be in that time
remember remember I said if let's grant
that the Quran has other scientific
claims true that it got some things
right if it got one of these things
wrong then it's not from God that's what
that's what we agreed to yeah but but if
I didn't agree with that and and I held
the same position that you do towards
the Bible then it it wouldn't get us
anywhere well it would mean that you
can't use this argument as a proof that
Islam is true now it would mean that you
would have to drop this idea that
scientific Miracles prove the Quran
because if you do that then you'll get
you're in trouble in saying that you
know you well you're in trouble because
you'll run into stuff like this where
the Quran actually gets scientific
things absolutely wrong okay okay okay
makes sense again for the people in like
the comments that are saying stuff about
me I I'm not like a practicing Muslim
like I I was just experiment you know
I'm not very Ed educated in in this
sense I guess is what I'm trying to say
but uh logic thank you so much of course
bro thank you I'll I'll look into do you
have anything that I should look into um
yes look into child marriage in Islam
wait child marriage yeah and and and
stuff proving that's Christian the
Christian like God is real you know when
you that's proving because I know I know
you can't prove this type of thing but
like any evidence I mean this is what
I'll do this is what I do okay and
hopefully I see you more often but I'm
going to crush I'm going to destroy
destroy the falsehood of Islam so that
it frees you to receive the truth of
Jesus until I bring down the wall of
Islam I don't believe that you can
clearly see Christ yet that's why I do
it like this so once I show you how
false Islam is cu that's what you're
like in the midst of right now you're in
Islam I'mma show you that that's false
and then I'mma show you the gospel how
the gospel is true how the Bible is true
the church the the history of the church
is true I'm going to show you all of
that all right okay so where do I start
child marriages yeah I want you to look
into that do you do you believe that God
would uh permit permit child marriage
child sex relations no but yeah no no
yeah so straight up no so if there is a
religion saying that God said child
marriage is okay allowing child sex
relations right getting married to them
consummating them before puberty and all
that kind of stuff we know that that's a
false religion right that that's not
from God that's that's that's satanic
some like that can also be said about
like slavery in in in and go over and we
can go over that stuff and show you and
clear up the misconception as I like I
told you I'm going show you the
falsehood in Islam that you're in and
I'm going to show you the truth of the
gospel and all your objections bring
them and we'll clear up everything okay
all right so I hope I see you again man
soon sooner than later all all the time
wait so so I should follow you right
yeah dude and if you want to message
yeah message me and you know if you okay
let's start a beautiful friendship we
homies now I'm following YouTube okay
thank you all right peace bro I I will I
will thank you peace bro how do I exit
this all right I got you I I'll drop you
yeah yeah